bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj oggi sono contentissimo
perché sto per iniziare penombra
necrologi per chi lo conoscesse penombra
e una delle serie horror più di successo
del mio canale inizi è stato proprio uno
dei primissimi video in assoluto sono
usciti questi nuovi capitoli che non ho
mai giocato di prima è penombra
necrologi e direi che possiamo partire
letto scimmia ronchi cimiano pietro non
è in questo video se stai sbagliando
enzo angela mia amica swanson bella ma
va bene grazie cook e non sono una
scimmia però se ti piace così
che ti devo dire sono vivo è un sogno
non lo so però se in una stanza di merda
quello sicuro volevo dirvi ragazzi che
ne sono usciti due adesso sta facendo il
terzo di penombra nuovi e che non ho mai
giocato
quindi c'è questo e un altro ancora
completo non vedo l'ora di giocarlo per
ora di non dormire la notte ragazzi
siamo all'inizio della nostra avventura
let's golf c'è un computer o possono
gare su facebook bene come sono fatti
gli swans nella tipo di prima che non mi
la coprì ma devo sfruttare questa gente
la mia bella si parte con la circondava
tata subito subito subito la patata
arrivare che un piacere a me nonostante
io sia un posto del delle palle gol
basta stai zitto mi dà fastidio
madonna c'è uno nudo salve
clarence mai a salve ho visto una lucera
che non sono pazzo
ci sono delle piante brutte no ragazze
lo giuro su dio ho visto una luce non
sono pazzo
non sono pazzo ma in tutti i posti di me
dove potevo svegliarvi non potevo
svegliarmi a gardaland in quei posti lì
non ho devo svegliarmi qua pazzo maniaco
o per una volta ha funzionato una roba
che ho fatto nella vita e ci stavo
pensando detto ma non funzionerà mai
cos'è quella roba lì io scendo e stato
bello
stiamo fuggendo da questo buongiorno
sono vivo a posto potevo anche buttarmi
di testa a quel punto va bene fa niente
dovremmo essere in antartide ragazzi
quindi c'è uno morto salve non le
stringo la mano perché ho paura di
staccargli la prendiamo di sopra già che
ci siamo mi spiace che il tipo sia morto
lì però non era fa non aveva visto
tunnel forze non c'è una cacca in tutto
questo perché siamo finiti a colori
doveva morire per forza la non potrà
venire qua l'acqua si sta congelando io
non so dove conduce contro questo tunnel
della persona qualche modo libero ok
abbassiamo lo seguiamo i tubi o mio dio
fa mi ci deve sempre fare il sangue per
terra
ecco questo non è positivo ma fa niente
avviato la radio radio maria aiol di
rousse dentro di me bravo capitolo vuol
dire che se io esco di qua mi salvo la
vita ma lo stesso tempo in disprezzo
l'essere umano che non sa che dire
condor sei parà uccisi ma che lega il
monache a maggio bruna si può salire
sopra che è successo qua veramente 15
proprio mi ha sbloccato un'altra area
spaccato il soffitto va bene ma la
nostra ghazi vedo l'ora di prendermi il
primo infarto in questo giochino stato
contento leva non so neanche cosa serve
però io giro si sa mai ha preso
sbloccato l'acqua sai infatti la sento
che schifo
vado 18 mi sa che ho tirato in su
l'acqua quella che ci riconduce va al
punto di prima
ora cavalcare male che cadono le
caviglie
p no no no no no non hai capito non è
capito scavo stavo scherzando ma poi
domanda cosa ci facevi tu qua sotto
c'era la melma pif sei tu
ho visto qualcuno correre e che finita
ma scusa magari qua no raga non è
possibile non sono pazzo prendi sotto
tubo infilato qua bene non ho capito
cosa sia successo però vabbè mi fate
andare avanti che mi caga addosso stare
qui giuro che ho visto un tizio era che
non sono falso prima vedo luci poi vedo
tizi che girano speriamo il dio di non
trovarmi con l'affare da un momento
all'altro in faccia se successo sul
rumore
no ragazzi avete sentito anche voi cos'è
altro rumore qui orribile cose qua o
eccolo nostra chiave dei chiave devo
aprire una porta che non so quale ma va
bene guardiamo indietro acquamadre tutta
tua madre morta gesù cristo
io che prova finale chiavi nei matura
sorella ma riprendiamo con il gameplay
ciao pif questa è la parte che mi ha
mangiato la famiglia nonino
vorrei chiudere questa porta qui che non
si chiude perché cerco le scuole porca
vacca morta se la sono studiate alla bio
sta roba signori
l'obiettivo è arrivare a trovare un
cacciavite per aprire il condotto di
ventilazione elevarci alle male però a
quanto pare pif non ci fa passare ciao
pif quanti anni sono passati sei sempre
più bello vorrei capire dove sei però io
devo entrare in quella stanza che
l'unica che si è aperta
bravo fratello vai bravissimo
quindi le porte chirico la porta va la
mamma mia cortesia pd ma mi salva la
partita
gesù giuseppe e maria mi sono pagato
come ledro
buongiorno a vedi che cela cacciavite
qui prendi cacciavite adesso tornano
indietro ma io era da una vita che non
mi calavo così addosso per un gioco c'è
proprio secondo me i giochi tipo amnesia
penombra stone ha fatto un passo avanti
a tutto a tutto in rovina sbagliato al
codice
chissenefrega tanto lo sfida qua
benissimo sono proprio contento mannaia
marchi ma inventato
mamma mia quanto mi ricordo dei vecchi
tempi però tu non è che puoi fare la
minchia che vuoi ha chiuso la porta a
sorte spaccare quel coso averi che c'è
la mano qui non avevo vista ma dove sei
pezzente
mi scusi entro quale faccio compagnia
theory si sta si sta bene qui è un po
pallido dovrebbe abbronzarsi un
pochettino senta apra la bocca dica no
facevo io ho trovato un flop i floppy
disk live ai codici faccio la foto
ragazzi perché mi devo ricordare quello
che c'è scritto a me l'avesse la
presente nel presente il taccuino
perfetto dobbiamo trovare una roba dove
posso scrivere il codice capito io
ragazzi l'unica roba di codice che mi
ricordo stava nella stanza di prima di
tori devo risalire qua dentro
teoricamente allora i codici sono 37 15
37 15
niente a ecco porco demonio e medi che
funziona la volete inserito male vamonos
dritti a mirabilandia
non siamo parlati permesso
[Musica]
perché sono amico di pietro me lo sono
sempre chiesto anche io facciamo che non
rimaniamo quando rimaniamo pagina alla
gira gira gira gira gira gira gira gira
veloce è quanto tempo mamma che ci ho
passato però che non ci passi
quell'altro nova cosa
così che ce li dentro vi prego aiuto
junior i giovani e non ci arriva qua non
ci arriva chiuso te ne vai dalla mia
vita ci sono un sacco di posti dove vuoi
andare a divertirti basta se lo seguo
teoricamente non dovrebbe girarsi se si
gira mi ammazzo oh mio dio ce l'ho fatta
non tornata una scala mamma mia oh non
dire che non si apre che ti ammazzo
perfetto un'ansia che non avete idea
mamma mia ragazzi gioco assurdo allora
pensate ragazzi che sto bagno fa
veramente schifo ma in confronto al
posto di prima ebbe un parco giochi per
promette bene qua c'è un cervello qua
questo lo portiamo a pietro da ecco è lo
portiamo sfuso non solo pif e brutto
come la morte ma si porta dentro pure la
torcia quindi quando vede una luce e
mica going ma non posso entrare qua ma
guarda che volentieri stavo davvero
davvero prima è però va bene ma anche
perché non capisce mai se sti cosi salve
buongiorno notavo viso non capisce mai
se sti cosi si alzano ma sono loro in
miniatura come sono feti di pif pizzetti
ti regalo un amico si sa mai che un
altro effetto ha trovato mio cammino
questa volta un morto
anche io sono infetto sto portando il
virus ciò vuol dire che se scappa da
questo posto lo porto in tutto il mondo
che va bene basta che che sopravvive
per un attimo si è svolta la musica e mi
sono cagato nelle mutande chili quando
negli horror si toglie la musica è
veramente un casino quanto ci fate che
quell affare si sveglia in 0,3 secondi
c'è la croce sul muro l'avevo vista io
io non posso giocare a questa roba non
ce la posso fa non ce la posso fare io
mio mi sono cagato addosso ma tranquilli
non lo so è svegliato non si è svegliato
la porta ancora chiusa bene tutto come
fa niente
tutto a posto questa è bloccata a cola
lino si apre vero nov i tre ragazzi io
gioco giochi horror che mi fanno saltare
il cuore in gola veramente non esistono
più se non tipo out la sun che sono
veramente pochi e questo è assurdo
assurdo cieli giuro mi sta per essere
tornate vecchi tempi ha fatto benissimo
qua c'è una freccia vabbè se aperto la
libreria dietro la libreria su un
passaggio ma sto male passo gioco
incredibile ma è meglio degli altri per
umbra mio dio
cosa si sono inventati fantastico raga
lega tutto qua ragazzi tutto qua perché
finiamo sempre in posti più brutti di
quelli poi ce ne vuole
ce ne vuole vediamo se mi trovo delle
batterie anche mezza proprio no proprio
per abbattere parola tazza sì o mio dio
vi prego non mi fate fare cose difficili
ecco guarda mi va bene tutte le cose
peggiori della mia vita e potevano
succedere successo il buio ragni tutto
se ci sono dei reni in questo gioco io
cambio gioco ragazzi ve lo dico prima
facciamo patti chiari amicizia lunga va
bene gli orali non li sopporto non si
sposterà
non posso uscire posso vedere
laboratorio da qui posso uscire per
favore fatemi uscire che i ragni non li
sopporto nella vita questo lo sapete già
perché mi mettete i ragni giochi non
poté non potevate fare gli spaventi
senza i ragni no ragazzi veramente a
parte gli scherzi anni non li reggo però
in questo primo episodio vi sia piaciuto
non vedo l'ora di continuarlo anche
perché penombra fa parte del mio cuore e
del mio cuore nel senso che tra un po mi
parte il collasso però va beh
per questo vi sia piaciuto lasciate come
ha scritto un commento mi piace
schiacciata la campanella così che
arrivano le notifiche di noi e noi come
sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo vivo
da ragazzi
[Musica]